Have you ever wanted to go to Mars but just
couldn’t find the time?
Well, you might be in luck!
Hey guys, Julia here with DNews.
People continue to be fascinated with Mars,
with numerous planned missions from the US,
Russia and China as well as private companies
preparing to colonize the Red Planet.
But, it’s not that easy, getting to Mars
takes money, fuel and well, time.
How much time?
Well, not taking into account developing technology,
training crews, and the fact that the Earth
and Mars are constantly moving, forcing missions
to have to wait until the two planets are
at an optimal alignment, the distance from
here to there is really far and the journey
takes a really long time.
The average distance between Earth and Mars
is about 140 million miles (225km.)
And let's say we send the fastest spacecraft
we’ve ever launched, NASA’s New Horizons,
on a mission to Mars.
If it maintained its launch speed of 36,000
mph, which it wouldn’t, the journey would
still take 162 days.
That is a lot of time for something to go
wrong.
So what if I told you that in the near future
we might be able to do that exact same journey
in just three days?
Sounds impossible, right?
But it very much could be a reality all thanks
to photon driven propulsion.
A paper written by physicist Philip Lubin
titled A Roadmap to Interstellar Flight outlines
this technology and how we can use it to further
explore the universe.
Currently NASA uses chemical propulsion, or
burning fuel to accelerate and launch their
spacecraft.
Photon propulsion is an idea that would use
light particles, called photons, instead.
It is similar to the idea of solar sails that
use light rays from our sun, which bounce
off a reflective surface, creating a small
amount of energy that propels the craft forward.
But instead of the sun, this plan would use
a hypothetical space laser that would be launched
into orbit around Earth.
The laser, in theory, would be powerful enough
to project the craft, which is currently proposed
as a wafer thin vessel, to interstellar speeds.
Lubin suggests this could propel small vessels
to 26% the speed of light.
And even though this project is similar to
a solar sail, it’s also very different.
Light from a laser will be highly concentrated,
opposed to the light coming off our massive
sun, which gets weaker the farther away it
travels.
A concentrated laser beam would effectively
be more efficient at long distances in order
to propel an object faster and further.
So, all this means we can start sending people
to Mars over a long weekend, right?
Well, not any time soon.
Even though the math might be there to prove
this theory, the size of this project would
be expensive.
That’s why Lubin proposes to start small,
and eventually scale up to one day accommodate
manned photon propulsion flights.
But keep in mind the name of his paper, A
Roadmap to Interstellar Flight.
He is thinking bigger than Mars.
Photon propulsion would be able to send small
crafts to the farthest reaches of the universe
with no fuel to worry about and in a fraction
of the time currently possible.
That would mean the ability to visit and document
other stars and exoplanets.
In fact, Lubin calculates it would only take
17 years to send a small craft to Alpha Centauri,
the closest star system to us, about 4 light
years away.
Again, this isn’t science fiction, Lubin
is currently working on proton propulsion
with NASA in a program called DEEP IN, or
Directed Energy Propulsion for Interstellar
Exploration.
And others have been working on the idea of
photon propulsion.
Dr. Young Bae, who is also working with NASA
on photon propulsion actually has a video
showing a one pound weight moving across a
track using just light from a laser.
But there is still a lot of obstacles to overcome
to achieve intergalactic space travel.
Like how to slow down something traveling
that fast, how to send back data from 4 light
years away and creating a laser strong enough
to make this all possible.
But for now, let’s just sit back and dream
of a world where you can send a care package
to your friend living on Mars in 3 days or
less.
So, where would you send a probe to if you
didn’t have to worry about how long it would
take?
Tell us in the comments below and subscribe
here for more DNews, thanks for watching.